the first time you're exposed to
permutations and combinations it takes a
little bit to get your brain around it
so and I think it never hurts to do as
many examples but each incremental
example I'm gonna go I'm gonna review
what we've done before but hopefully go
a little bit further so let's just take
another example and this isn't the same
thing and in the next and videos after
this I'll start using other examples
other than just people sitting in chairs
but let's stick with it for now so let's
say we have six people again so person a
b c d e and f so we have six people and
now let's put them into four chairs and
we can go through this fairly quickly
one two three four chairs and we've seen
this show multiple times how many ways
how many permutations are there of
putting these six people into four
chairs well the first chair if we see
them in order we might as well we could
say well there'd be six possibilities
here now for each of those six
possibilities there would be five
possibilities of who we put here because
one person's already sitting down now
for each of these thirty possibilities
of seating these first two people
there'd be four possibilities of who we
put in chair number three and then for
each of these what is this 120
possibilities there would be three
possibilities of who we put in chair
four and so this 6 times 4 times 6 times
5 times 4 times 3 is the number of
permutations and we've seen in one of
the early videos on permutations that or
when we talk about the permutation
formula one way to write this if we
wanted to write it in terms of factorial
we could write this as as six factorial
six factorial which is going to be equal
to 6 times 5 times 4 times 3 times 2
times 1 but we want to get rid of the 2
times 1 so we're going to divide that
we're gonna divide that now what's 2
times 1 well 2 times 1 is 2 factorial
and where did we get that well we wanted
the first for the first 4 factors of 6
factorial so if you want and that's
where the 4 came from we wanted the
first 4 factors and so the way we've got
2 is we said 6-4 6-4 that's going to get
us what we want to get that that's going
to give us the number that we want to
get rid of all right so we wanted to get
rid of two or the factors we want to get
rid of
so that's going to give us two factorial
so if we use six minus four factorial
then that's going to give us two
factorial which is two times one and
then these cancel out and we are all set
and so this is one way this is you know
I put in the particular numbers here but
this is a review of the permutations
formula where people say hey if I'm
saying and if I'm thinking N Things and
I want to figure out how many
permutations are there putting them into
let's say K spots it's going to be equal
to n factorial over n minus K factorial
that's exactly what we did over here
where six is N and K or four is K four
is K actually let me color code the
whole thing so that we see so that we
see the so that we see the parallel now
all of that is review but then we went
into the world of combinations and in
the world of combinations we said okay
permutations permutations make a
difference between who's sitting in what
chair so for example in the permutations
world this is all review we've covered
this in the first combinations video and
the permutations world a b c d and d a b
c these would be two different
permutations that's being counted in
whatever number of the Cistus is what
this is 30 times 12 this is this is
equal to this is equal to 360 so this is
each of these this is one permutation
this is another permutation and if we
keep doing it we would count up to 360
but we learned in combinations when
we're thinking about combinations let me
write combinations so if we're saying
and choose and choose K or how many
combinations are there if we take K
things and we just want to figure out
how many combination so if we start with
n if your pool of N Things and we want
to say how many combinations of K things
are there then we would count these as
the same combination so what we really
want to do is we want to take the number
of permutations there are we want to
take the number of permutations there
are which is equal to
and factorial over n minus K factorial
over n minus K factorial and we want to
divide by the number of ways that you
could arrange for people once again and
this takes I remember the first time I
learned it took my brain a little while
so if it's taking a little while to
think about it not a big deal it's it's
it can be confusing at first but it'll
hopefully if you keep thinking about it
hopefully you will see clarity at some
moment but what we want to do is we want
to divide by all of the ways that you
could arrange for things because once
again and the permutations it's counting
all of the different arrangements of
four things but we don't want to count
all of those different arrangements of
four things we want to just say well
they're all one combination so we want
to divide by the way the number of ways
to arrange four things now if or the
number of ways to arrange K things so
let me write this down so what is the
number of ways number of ways to arrange
K things K things in K spots and I
encourage you to pause the video because
this is actually a review from the first
permutation video well if you have K
spots let me do it so this is the first
spot the second spot third spot and then
you're gonna go all the way to the cait
spot well for the first spot there could
be K possibilities
there's K things that could take the
first spot now for each of those K
possibilities how many things could be
in the second spot well it's gonna be K
minus one cuz you already put you
already put something in the first spot
and then over here was it gonna be K
minus two all the way to the last spot
there's only one thing that could be put
in the last spot so what is this thing
here K times K minus 1 times K minus 2
times K minus 3 all the way down to 1
well this is just equal to K factorial
the number of ways to arrange K things
in K spots K factorial the number of
ways to arrange four things in four
spots that's four factorial the number
of ways to arrange three things in three
spots it's three factorial so we could
just divide this we could just divide
this by K factorial
and so this would get us this would get
us n factorial divided by K factorial K
factorial x times n minus K factorial
and minus K and minus K and I'll put the
factorial right over there and this
right over here is the formula this
right over here is the formula for
combinations sometimes this is also
called the binomial coefficient people
will call this n choose K they'll also
write it like this and choose K
especially when they're thinking in
terms of binomial coefficients but let's
I got into kind of an abstract tangent
here when I started getting into the the
general formula but let's go back to our
example so in our example in our example
we saw there was a 360 ways of seating
six people into four chairs but what if
we didn't care about who's sitting in
which chairs and we just want to say how
many ways are there to choose four
people from a pool of six well that
would be that would be how many ways are
there so that would be six how many
combinations if I'm starting with a pool
of six how many combinations are there
how many combinations are there four
selecting four or another way of
thinking about it is how many ways are
there to from a pool of six items people
in this example how many ways are there
to choose four of them and that is going
to be you know we could do it and then
I'll reason through it and like I always
say I don't I'm not a huge fan of the
formula every time I you know I
revisited after a few years I actually
just reread think about it as opposed to
memorizing it because memorizing is a
good way to not understand what what's
actually going on but if we just applied
the formula here but I really understand
I really want you to understand what's
happening with the formula it would be
six factorial over four factorial over
four factorial times 6 minus 4 factorial
six whoops let me actually let me just
so this is 6 - 4 factorial so this part
right over here 6 - 4 or 5 actually let
me write it out because I know this can
be a little bit confusing the first time
you see it so 6 minus 4 factorial
factorial which is equal to which is
equal to 6 factorial over 4 factorial
over 4 factorial times this thing right
over here is 2 factorial times 2
factorial which is going to be equal to
we could just write out the factorial 6
times 5 times 4 times 3 times 2 times 1
over 4 4 times 3 times 2 times 1 times
times 2 times 1 and of course that's
going to cancel with that and then the 1
really doesn't change the value so let
me get rid of this one here and then
let's see this 3 can cancel with this 3
this 4 could cancel with this 4 and then
it's 6 divided by 2 is going to be 3 and
so we are just left with 3 times 5 so we
are left with we are left with there's
15 combinations there's 360 permutations
for putting 6 people into 4 chairs but
there's only 15 combinations because
we're no longer counting all of the
different arrangements for the same four
people in the four chairs we're saying
hey if it's the same four people that is
now one combination and you could see
how many ways are there to arrange four
people into four chairs well that's the
4 factorial part right over here the 4
factorial part right over here which is
4 times 3 times 2 times 1 which is 24 so
we just essentially just took the 360
divided by 24 to get 15 but once again I
don't want to strike him I don't think I
can stress this enough I want to make it
clear where this is coming from this
right over here let me circle this piece
right over here is the number of
permutations and this is really just so
you can get to 6 times 5 times 4 times 3
it was exactly what we did up here
reason through it and then we just want
to divide by the number of ways you can
arrange for items in four spaces